foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
you forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones update
video in this new video I want to
discuss everything that has been
happening within the Game of Thrones and
The Song of Ice and Fire universe as you
all know HBO is secretly working on a
new show about one of their most
recognizable characters Jon Snow if you
had been watching all of my videos then
you know this is something I have been
discussing for about half of the year at
the beginning of the summer George RR
Martin revealed HBO and Game of Thrones
actor Kit Harington have been working on
a new show about the life of Jon Snow
set after the events and the finale of
the original series on his website
George R Martin revealed a lot of new
information about this show not only
have HBO and Kit Harington been working
on this show for a number of years but
Mr Harrington has also brought on a lot
of his own friends as writers and
directors this information has been
confirmed again and again by other Game
of Thrones actors who've had one-on-one
discussions with Kit Harington as of
right now HBO still hasn't made their
own official announcement about their
show however I think that may no longer
be the case after this weekend we might
finally hear something official from HBO
this weekend during their first ever
Game of Thrones fan convention literally
right now as we speak they are holding
an official Game of Thrones fan
convention in the city of Los Angeles
many of the Game of Thrones in-house of
the Dragon actors will be there
interacting with the fans now what makes
this even more exciting is the fact that
Mr Harrington is there as well another
very interesting thing I noticed was how
HBO uploaded a new Jon Snow video on
their official YouTube channel it seemed
very random in and out of the blue
because they didn't upload any other
Game of Thrones videos regarding any of
their other fan favorite characters from
the show what I find even more
interesting was how this video was named
Jon Snow's Journey which is more or less
what this new show will be about the new
Jon Snow sequel series will follow Jon
Snow after the events of Game of Thrones
we will basically see Jon Snow's Journey
after he was sent north of the wall I
think HBO might have uploaded this video
as a way to get fans ready for the new
show they have in development hopefully
we will get some sort of official
announcement this weekend during their
first ever fan convention in Los Angeles
while kid Arrington is there as their
guest of honor we may finally get some
of the answers we have been looking for
so stay tuned and keep your eyes open
now HBO is most likely watching these
videos as a way to see how much
excitement and interest there actually
is for a show like this so don't hold
back now if you really want to see this
show then you have to let them know down
in the comment section I would assume
they're watching and wondering how we
all feel about this idea for a new show
let them know that the fans still have
their back and I will be the first to
say it if HBO or Mr Harrington is
watching this video I really hope you're
able to get this show made Game of
Thrones might be over but that doesn't
mean we have to see the last of Jon Snow
I know I'll be here alongside hundreds
of thousands or even millions of fans
anxiously awaiting for the arrival of
another show so for the love of the old
gods and the new all I ask is that you
release something to let us know it's
still on the way on behalf of most of
the Game of Thrones fans I think it's
safe to say we're ready for more as
always I want to thank everyone for
stopping by and watching this video I
hope all of you have a great day I will
see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
foreign